how's government but a fire where's the
photo then I was too far welcome back to
him Nisha I lost the lights you should
be here
don't tell me no so I took him
Hana hello okay I think we need to check
the other rooms is now we have a key
that goes to the prison door I don't
really know what it
guess we'll find out I guess we'll find
out number two v you and me wait let me
make it cozy fire you're looking fine
there sir
what that is weird this is awkward
so JP there it's like hey if you like it
wait what why do I say these things I'm
sorry I feel awkward by myself
that should not be possible anyway now
I'm awkward hope you're happy
oh no are you Bros feeling all right
what do we got here I think I I am what
is that
what is that it looks disgusting
oh yeah yeah get the [ __ ] out of way you
[ __ ] battle try to block my way
nope let's [ __ ] Asami don't know me bro
all right what is this all right I have
this hey Mouse [ __ ] why are they so
heavy [ __ ] up hey why is it so narrow
[ __ ] my face John damn yo you thought
you throw it I'm it in yeah whoa what is
it hello god damn it I hate tons of
[ __ ] naked guys yeah you [ __ ] you
maybe go back didn't ya
you tricked me dad I lost sense of
direction or did I dad I
okay kangaroo
[ __ ] alright let's go it out what is
this Oh No ha ha oh [ __ ]
what's up i with that okay with that
I hated that all right I pick up what is
this the finer coins whoa Oh another
mindfuck moment it's up for now
I was playing the piano in the prison
that doesn't make any sense
can I go in these I don't think so well
oh there's a light here they obviously
want me to go here all right I'm gone
like don't even worry about it Bret
don't even work I don't trust this all
right
don't try hello a candle whatcha doin
I don't what what what happened eh I
couldn't move oh no it's not good for my
heart God David
all right what do I do now get up get up
what it's up with all this I just choose
whichever I want all right all right
fine
I feel like I've been here though
I really do
I don't what all right let's lift this
oh no not that
ah yeah god damn it ah ha ha nice this
is not nice Gitmo caboose okay okay okay
uh what am i doing is you're good all
right all right oh [ __ ] just don't come
in here
it's gonna come in here
oh thank heavens what is this oh I can
clean my exhale
I did have to make it awesome alright
all right you [ __ ] battle you know
like this didn't yeah but it's going on
here
a choppa what about this oh haha
clatter nananana nanana potatoes where
well he's going there alright I want to
shake this door out actually and then we
need to Clara likes it so he actually
went in here oh it's like well I guess
for a good reason
maybe I can put it here nah nah nah okay
I don't know where to put it
where
Oh No
no come on I didn't do anything
seriously everywhere in this game it's
like give me a break
I'll go over here that's fine Oh
Jennifer I love you love you right oh
okay I'm glad I can actually move you
car say I'm not that fat pinnate Shh
you're still fine well what the [ __ ] I
feel a strange force in this corridor
I'm not going there I just can't stand
for some reason Jennifer did you put a
force field but I love your pair okay
just Jesus Christ desperate well what do
we do if there's a force field
I don't like force fields they're not
good
I may be something here
hello did I walk in a circle I think I
[ __ ] did good job maybe here what is
hurting me
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm Rea I got what I came
for the flux key that the flux it hello
sir black key ah all right
so done with this place ah stupid nope
note ain't got [ __ ] on me ain't got [ __ ]
on me all right second room cleared
Shh I don't know what that was but hey
that was pretty sweet
it wasn't I can do better
well I'll try better next time all right
next time totally gonna nail it
alright room Nome no I'm bad at that ass
Oh what is this what's playing the piano
seryozha but where is everybody but I
had acid do I do with this [ __ ] coin
I think it's in here anyway
Oh cab no way I got to do it after I
finish it don't keep burping
ah hey this place isn't so bad
what what was that this is actually kind
of cool all right this is a puzzle the
flux machine is the best way of locking
things out you need your self Natsuki a
square pipe flows directly to the
triangle but your angle has two ways of
operating one to block the system and
want to flow the steam into the air you
need to divert the steam to the circle
the gate is still long and you need a
flux key to block the system to unlock
the game all right I'll just put it I
guess ah
hey that's panic I wait the head so like
Jesus Christ Ursula I'm sorry I came as
fast like a dog what about it pits solve
this puzzle I thought I did I piss good
job holy [ __ ] so as an MultiJet genius
appeared a very good job I love your pee
what I mean I hate you okay good now
keep going what the hell do I go that
this place gives me the creeps
let's get out of here fast pits oh Jesus
Christ never stop hitting it don't you
it's not my fault I just I can't help it
it's just how I roll it's how you get
all the ladies pity let's get three and
you don't get any ladies do you know ha
yeah [ __ ] all right [ __ ] them darling
nobody going just keep walking
Wow does this keep happening Mike come
from here okay let's keep going up I
guess
it's without the quarry noise oh sorry
observe and I just need it
shake the rims really quick I'll out I
don't think there's anything in these
rooms I don't think I need my legend
either know what happened in here they
try to cut not on my watch stupid things
alright so that was pretty pointless
dance this guy's pretty can you put me
down more normal for once
sorry Spanish but I'm a just good guy
alright I get the feeling I missed
something but hey that gives a [ __ ]
alright we're on the top floor what do
we do here I done a pretty keep looking
alright I'm putting it down gently buddy
good job today
you suck what it's identic oh no all
right we all chosen the block to the
great wall you think you like why should
we block it
no it's living it's a living heart of it
the floors are amazing with such talking
to the bad guys so much people died in
there we didn't have my sugar choice a
block at the funeral and we're now all
right it sounds like the worst place in
the world I have no choice to save them
fine I'll do it
goddamnit why do I keep wasting my Latin
and beautiful places all right I just
don't really know what's going on here
ah how's easy get down at the right
place
hey can you go down go down that's what
she said come on go down seriously I
don't [ __ ] with me right now I'm
Savannah I gotta put you here because I
need to look around a little bit
don't worry about this obviously okay
good okay there we go
ah I love I know we all think about the
block to block the Great Wall a big
shelf don't like it there are three
levers two in each room the third lever
is stuck when you found all the levers
okay so two in each room does it make
sense if it's three of them I mean I
guess that means I got a look they're
not gonna be a level in here kids not be
silly
I am salad that's what I do all right oh
okay fine you know what I don't give a
[ __ ] Thank You Missy I quite frankly no
one cares
but what rooms all of these rooms
I don't I don't get it I don't say it 11
so just say only letters perhaps I quite
frankly didn't find out in lab nice haha
I checked you that in that what you
don't do anything good do something good
there's something good come on
well enemies we got to find another one
it's probably meant over here maybe
behind another one of us pairs of
solving puzzles like it's nobody's
business
I mean it's everyone's business all you
tried to cook not on my watch not on my
watch
no I got my watch Jesus Christ our heart
can be alright where's the lever don't
nest on the very serious side what are
you what what is this what are you doing
there
why is Earth yeah whatever you don't do
anything do you I pull all of them a my
eyes itching
all right I put I put I swear to God I
put oh no it's not I don't God holy [ __ ]
how do I get past these oh hello so
stupid son of a [ __ ] I thought it would
you can never know where he comes from
don't be like that
I tried so Jason skies you suck kids
my mama's peasants better than ya how do
you know that don't question me all
right sorry
the forbidden Hotel snore ooh that
sounds scary
all right breasts after this awkward
long stare
[Music]
ah all right come on
oh my god this place feels so evil was
this really a good idea to go in here
well I'm Stefano hello welcome to the
Great Hall where your wish has come true
not really all right I'm gonna have said
it I can be enjoyed both subscribe come
over today I know there was a lot of
puzzle not that much action well I could
be one anyways yeah you know I love you
save dog or carne
oh my god dog it's so handsome but I
could get laid
but dog is so handsome but I could get
laid but dog play no